Greek Prime Minister Alexis Tsipras has arrived in North Macedonia,...
...the first ever official visit by a Greek leader to its neighboring country...
...after decades of strained relations over a naming dispute.
In Algeria, President Abdelaziz Bouteflika's...
...long-awaited announcement of his departure has fallen flat,...
...as protesters and opposition figures say it does not go far enough...
...to satisfy demands for dramatic change to the country's power structure.
The UN says 900,000 doses of cholera vaccine have arrived in Mozambique...
...to help prevent an epidemic amid reports...
...the disease has affected more than 1,000 people...
...in areas affected by Cyclone Idai.
In India, less than two weeks before the national election,...
...India's main opposition party, the Indian National Congress,...
...has released a manifesto promising policies to financially support the poor...
...and bring together a country they say is divided.
Finally from China, the local authorities say that a forest fire...
...that killed at least 30 people in the country's southwestern Sichuan Province has been contained.